the ceos of top technology companies
will face very hard questions on capitol
hill next week
about the spread of misinformation and
their ability to control what is posted
the capital siege on january 6 was
fueled by false claims of election fraud
much of the planning also took place
online cbs news senior investigative
correspondent catherine harris shares
new exclusive details
about twitter's decision to shut down
tens of thousands of accounts
linked to the conspiracy theory q anon
[Applause]
after rioters pushed their way into the
capital on january
6 to violently block the electoral
college certification
twitter now tells cbs news the social
media platform
purged more than a hundred and fifty
thousand accounts
associated with q anon that's double the
number
previously reported there are folks on
one side who say that the platforms
are censoring and taking down free
speech and there are others who say the
platforms
aren't doing enough alexandra gibbons
leads the center for democracy and
technology
that promotes laws and policy supporting
free speech
deciding to remove someone from a social
media account does have significant
impact on their ability to find other
people to express their views and to
communicate
you're not going on camera because you
have significant security concerns
that's that's correct
senior twitter officials tracking the q
and on conspiracy theory agreed to speak
with cbs
news on the condition their identities
were protected
do you both receive threats according to
these officials
most of the shuttered accounts belong to
americans not so called bots
computer software designed to spread
misinformation
twitter told us they used machine
learning and some human review
to determine the accounts that violated
their coordinated harmful activity
policy
after the riots suspended users were
notified
and allowed to appeal the officials said
the success rate of appeals was
near zero and they have high confidence
in their decisions
twitter officials said many of the same
accounts suspended
were first monitored as early as last
july
twitter began lowering the profile of
these accounts
based on q anon content posted who they
interacted with
as well as other online behaviors it's
one of the tools that platforms are
increasingly thinking about
is they try to balance this really hard
trade-off between the fear of silencing
speech
but also mitigating some of the concerns
about it when does
mitigating violence or mitigating
speech become censorship it's a hard
balance to strike
should twitter have done more and done
it sooner
there are a lot of disinformation
experts who think that the signs were on
the wall and action should have been
taken sooner
i think you can imagine that twitter was
struggling with the gravity
of the situation twitter used similar
tools against al qaeda and isis
to monitor and limit their terrorist
propaganda
asked if they used the same strategy
last summer against antifa supporters
as riots erupted in seattle and portland
twitter said
their approach was different when the
ideology leads someone
pointing to the fbi director's
congressional testimony that antifa
is an ideology not an organization
twitter officials say they want users to
have a quote
path back to healthy behavior and their
approach is focused on
de-radicalization and rehabilitation
twitter chief
jack dorsey recently told investors
users are
increasingly skeptical of his platform
we agree many people don't trust us
never has this been more pronounced than
the last few years
this isn't just about our actions to
promote healthy conversation
it goes broader and deeper asked if they
should have done more
sooner a twitter official said they
started taking action
as early as 2016 and they tried a
variety of enforcement options but after
january 6
more aggressive steps were needed on
rehabilitation and the role of a social
media company
they said it will take outside
partnerships bottom line
this is about free speech and the
intersection with social media anthony
so many tricky questions in the story
catherine thank you